welcome to the last session of the
workshop our anchor speaker is Laura
balsamic headline ah yes
great ok thank you everyone for coming I
wanted to say thank you to the
organizers for inviting me I was pleased
to be invited I predicted that I would
learn a lot and my prediction was right
it's been a really informative and
interesting week so like some other
speakers have said today in some
previous days what I do is a little bit
different than maybe the main theme of
this workshop but it has lots of similar
flavors
I work in model estimation and and
exploring that the applicability of
models to different kinds of data sets
and and building algorithms that do that
model estimation efficiently or in the
presence of some real-world problems
like missing data and things like that
and so today I'm going to tell you about
a particular type of model which you may
be familiar with called the subspace
clustering model and an algorithm to to
estimate that model so this work is
joint with my past PhD student John
Lumpur who's now professor in ECE at
Portland State University he you know
developed the algorithm and worked with
me on it in the first place and when we
saw its excellent performance and
potential for theoretical developments
we also enlisted the help of David Hong
who's another PhD student at Michigan
graduating this year and young shoten
who was a PhD student with Roman
vershinin but is now a postdoc here at
Berkeley so if you have any questions
you could ask any one of us four okay so
let me first tell excuse me tell you
what the subspace clustering model is
and motivate it with an example so
here's a data matrix it's a matrix of
gene expressions from different knockout
experiments and just like we've seen
many people talk about and talk
so far this matrix is low rank and maybe
we can leverage that structure for a
variety of reasons oh maybe we don't
have to take all of the measurements we
could interpolate measurements we could
identify outliers things like that okay
but actually it turns out that this
matrix has another interesting structure
if you were to take the columns and
cluster them in some way then each one
of those clusters itself is also low
range and not just the same rank but
smaller rank and you know in this case
the original matrix is about rank 61
with a very nice gap you can see and
these also have nice gaps but the
maximum rank of the sub matrix is 25
okay so in fact if you add these up
you'll conclude that these each are
linearly independent subspaces that we
can use in order to model these data
okay so this is an interesting model
first of all because often when we can
cluster data this way we believe there's
some meaningful reason you know these
experiments are all very similar they
have some similar consequence we have
some reason to think that we want to
cluster them and then maybe do some low
dimensional modeling but not only that
we can also think about this model as
being itself more parsimonious so you
know imagine we had these three clusters
and in a in a data set then we could
model it as 1 Rank 3 subspace or as
these three subspaces a plane in two
lines and in fact if we used the plane
in two lines we would have a better
opportunity of finding outliers that
were also in this subspace or perhaps
interpolating missing data obviously not
just in three dimensions but if we had
something much higher dimensional okay
so that's in fact the reason why this
model is applied in a variety of
contexts from genomics which I mentioned
to computer vision
and problems like face and object
identification in problems in computer
vision of object tracking or motion
through of objects through video and in
problems of computer network topology
identification where you have let's say
hot passively monitored hop count data
from different IP addresses and you'd
like to cluster them and interpolate
data so that's the subspace clustering
model and the reason why we're
interested in it and just to repeat it's
important that our context is we have
meaningful groups without labels so we
have to do something unsupervised to
identify them but the reason why I
stress that we have meaningful groups is
because we can still evaluate at the end
of the day based on our grouping right
it's not that we just have an objective
function but actually we want to see
that our final clusters have some
meaning okay and then we assume each
cluster itself has some geometric
structure in this case a low rank
structure so there's quite a bit of work
in this area starting twenty years ago
but really picking up in the last ten
years there are convex formulations
proofs of correct clustering you know
many non convex alternating algorithms
very similar to the one I'm going to
tell you about they work with compressed
data and noisy data and outliers there's
a very very vast amount of literature
but what we were interested in is
building an algorithm based on one which
is which is basically a very interesting
and fundamental objective which is the K
subspace clustering objective and we
were hoping because this is sort of a
very natural thing that people think to
do which I'll get to in just a second to
try to understand it better
and then if we're lucky you know try to
improve it in some way that that gets
better performance than other convex
formulations that are unrelated or we we
don't know yet if they're related to
this objective okay so the case of space
clustering objective is just a
generalization of k-means to the
situation where center points in the
clusters are not or centers are not
points but our planes okay so we just
have a k-means cost function with data
points x clusters denoted by C and then
subspace basis denoted by this u sub K
okay and we take the distance from X to
the nearest point in the subspace that
it's been assigned to and you could
think of that just as a projection onto
the center just the way that k-means is
okay okay so here we have then a
generalization of the k-means objective
their results a natural alternating
algorithm equivalent to the k-means
algorithm this was first derived and
presented about twenty years ago and the
algorithm is very natural we need to
know the number of clusters and the rank
of each subspace we start with some
initialization of subspaces here and
then we alternate we assign our clusters
according to projection whichever
subspace is closest you go in that
cluster and then we find the best rank
our subspace from that cluster of data
and repeat okay very simple very natural
algorithm okay now like k-means this
algorithm suffers from poor
initialization and other issues but
really in case subspaces it's much worse
than in k-means
you know in k-means it's not that hard
to find maybe if you run several
initializations to find a good one but
in case up spaces most of the
initializations are actually bad
initially
okay so here's just one example I have
400 data points in four clusters equally
balanced and this matrix here is an N by
n matrix which should be the co
sociation matrix so we're expecting to
get a block diagonal matrix here if we
did the right thing okay it's one yellow
if I plus turd those points together and
blue zero if I didn't cluster them
together okay so this is from a random
initialization and we could see that
it's a mess and it's not very good and
this isn't abnormal for K subspaces but
though we see it it looks kind of like a
mess we also see it doesn't look you
know completely unsalvageable there's
still some block behavior and in fact it
kind of looks like maybe these two
clusters have been sort of mixed
together in a way that we wouldn't want
and then you know these two clusters
have sort of been mixed together okay
and that's actually something that then
we could leverage so if each subspace
subspace output is you know not great
but not too bad we could think of it as
a weak clusterer an analogy to ensemble
learning in classification and then try
to use many weak clusters together in
order to get a good clustering output so
in fact if we just do five of these
random K subspaces initializations we
can see something much better and with
50 we can drive the clustering error
down to just 2% from 50% in the initial
clustering okay so that was the idea
that we had we yeah randomly exactly
you get something and you do that ten
times whatever they can't averaging
exactly so and what I'm a virgin is this
matrix which is one where I put the two
points together in zero otherwise so
it's like a co sociation matrix and then
I'm averaging it for some kind of
affinity for each time you run in to try
and get its clustering any notion of
either a threshold where it does not
well not well and then if you run along
enough to get so much better sort of
quickly sorry say it again a threshold
over time you mean yeah in iterations no
that's a good that's a good question
first first let me just say that so we
don't like pick a number of steps the
the while loop keeps going until nothing
changes okay and I'll tell you later
that this this always decreases the
objective or it stays the same so we can
count on that happening but secondly say
it again so so it depends on what you
mean by solution quality so when I say
solution quality I think of the
objective right because I don't have any
labels so if I evaluate the objective
then that is what's decreasing here but
if you have some side information or
something yeah there's a different thing
I guess you could yeah yeah yeah no and
I don't have those pots in here
unfortunately but I have some and it's
generally gradual and then it it stops
and when you know it looks like
something like this it actually is at a
place where it will not improve does
that help
if you had labels system you know the
truth you started with that does the
other you're iterating back and forth on
two matrices right okay sir oh so you
mean like if K equals two and I have one
subspace but I don't have them oh yeah
yeah yeah so we actually tried that so
let's see let me let me think back so so
we basically ran some K subspaces and
like took this as the output and tried
to we did something different because
because if this is the like this is a
local minimum in the sense that there is
no change that would be gotten by this
algorithm to give a change in the
objective so actually it would it would
stop here but maybe we could talk about
it offline because we've tried a lot of
different things and I'm sure one of
them is what you're talking about
that's what we're assuming for a sort of
simplicity right now when they don't
have the same rank it can be difficult
you basically upper bound it yeah yeah
yeah yeah no you're absolutely right so
you would use twenty five in that case
okay all right so this then inspired our
algorithm which I don't need to say
because it's sort of clear what we're
trying to do but I'll say it briefly we
have now just some distribution say like
the harm measure on the grass montien
from which we draw subspaces and then
some some base number of base
clusterings capital B and we'll Ron K
subspaces capital B times potentially in
parallel will get the clustering matrix
and average those for some affinity
matrix we also we have another parameter
QE we threshold that affinity matrix and
then we run spectral clustering so this
is the algorithm that I'll be talking
about and trying to say some things
about okay so before I tell you a little
bit about the
I just wanted to show you one set of the
results so the reason why we were really
excited and wanted to explore the theory
of this algorithm was because it's
clustering results were were definitely
state of the art so I can't tell if it's
visible to you but some of these entries
are bolded and across the board our
algorithm is in the top three of all the
algorithms and when we've tried new data
sets - we get a similar type of
performance so it works very well even
though it's really quite a very simple
algorithm okay so let me tell you what
we know you know starting with what we
know about K subspaces this base
algorithm that doesn't do any averaging
over the affinity matrices okay so first
it's pretty easy to see that since I
wrote the objective function similar to
K means there will be some hardness
results of course these are in worst
case right worst case instances exist so
that this is true but if we fix the rank
even to 1 then this objective it's
np-hard to approximate the objective
within some epsilon there exist some
epsilon maybe it's small but we can't
approximate smaller than that okay and
this has just gotten by a reduction to
k-means so that has a similar result
another one that's a little more
interesting is that if we instead fix
the number of clusters to two but let
the rank be input to the problem it
turns out it's np-hard to approximate
within any factor okay so we prove this
by proving that in this case it's
np-hard to decide whether the objective
is zero so in some sense maybe the K
subspaces problem is harder than the
k-means problem of course like I said
this is worst case but it kind of
motivates the fact that all the results
in subspace clustering assume a
generative model of the data that
they're trying to cluster in order to
prove something about their algorithm so
we're going to do the same
we're gonna assume our data are coming
from some underlying union of subspaces
how about by criteria for some some
kinds of by criteria sorry I'm I'm not
so familiar is it related to this
cluster through you know k equals three
that does as well as k equals two done
you know within some factor of the best
that could be done for k equals two oh I
see
yeah so meaning that if you you ran it
for a different set of parameters but
you could still be within some error on
this difference that is it also and be
hard to guarantee to make a guarantee
like that right that's a good question I
don't know the answer yeah
other questions yes so that's because
it's np-hard even to decide whether it's
zero yeah other questions
this is my foray into this field with a
colleague and computer science so I'd
love to know the kinds of questions that
people would ask about this ok so like I
said that kind of motivates the fact
that we're going to use generative
models to to make theoretical statements
about our algorithm now what was also
known about the case of spaces algorithm
before now initially actually as like I
said the objective function decreases at
every iteration and it reaches a local
optimum in the sense that you can't you
know move a cluster point to a different
cluster move a point to a different
cluster or we estimate subspaces and
have a better objective and there's a
set of initializations of nonzero
measure and in some cases most of the
space the initializations lead to a bad
local minimizer okay or not the global
minimizer okay so let's just get some
intuition of what we see happening from
a random initialization okay so I have a
500 by a thousand size data matrix and
I'm going to vary the rank and the
number of subspaces and the affinity
between the subspaces in the in the true
Union the underlying true Union and see
basically what happens when I run K
subspaces in this case I've have the
number of subspace is exactly equal to 5
but I'm increasing the rank from left to
right and the affinity is increasing
along the y axis so you know the
subspaces are very close together at the
top of these plots and what you see on
each row is a histogram over a hundred
runs of what the MIS clustering error
was from the K subspaces algorithm okay
so like this row right here the
affinities about 1/2 and
it basically does like 50% of the runs
had a 40% error and the other half had a
60% here okay so that's what this means
in this case here for example it just
always got it right at a hundred times
that have a zero error okay so what I
want you know you to notice from these
plots is that there's a real
discretization of the possible
clustering errors you can get in this
case for example you can get 20% 40% 60%
or 80% so basically what K subspaces is
doing is mixing up two of the clusters
or three of the clusters or mixing pairs
in four of the clusters okay so you
don't see something where it's just
drawing many points from many subspaces
you see this kind of you know air that's
structured okay and it you know holds
true and as the rank increases though
when you get a high enough dimension it
basically has enough space and the K
subspaces can overcome it so now these
plots K is decreasing two on the top
five on the bottom and you can see the
pattern that I've mentioned again so
when it's there's two we always get 50%
error when there's three we get 1/3 and
2/3 and so on ok so this really you know
motivates us gives us a feeling that
maybe we're right about each one of
these case subspaces initializations
being a weak cluster right it gives us
some partial information even though the
resulting clustering isn't great ok so
then what can we say about it this is
just an overview I'll say things briefly
and then I'll try to go a little bit
into each one so first we understand
that just from a random initialization
it clusters a pair of points with
probability monotonic in their absolute
inner product ok so the closer two
points are together in the data set the
more likely they are to be Co clustered
that makes sense
but we know it understand it in a in a
more precise way so recognizing that we
looked to another algorithm called
thresholded subspace clustering which
builds an affinity matrix exactly based
on the gram matrix so on the the
pairwise inner products and so we
generalized their theory to say for any
algorithm that builds an affinity matrix
whose IJ entry is the inner product of
the I and J data points in the data set
potentially changed by some monotonic
transformation and perturbed by some
bounded perturbation we can still have
good clustering okay so this model then
generalizes any any situation where we
may not have access to inner products
but we can only get some monotonic from
function of them approximately okay so
say you have missing data compressed
data data with outliers and noise you
don't have access directly to these
inner products but you have access to a
monotonic function of them at least an
expectation okay so we have that more
general theory and then we prove that
our ensemble K subspaces algorithm has
this some monotonic function of the
absolute inner products as expectation
for the random affinity matrix that we
get okay
so then of course if we can bound the
deviation meaning we can show this
concentrates then we can show that it
works in a variety of cases okay and I
have a star here so we didn't actually
do this for the alternating algorithm
only just an algorithm which says take a
random initialization cluster and stop
okay okay so I don't know exactly when I
started but five more minutes okay so
I'm just going to maybe tell you about
the first simple results and then the
the last theorem so like
said here random initializations cluster
a pair of points in a monotonic function
of their inner product so we were sort
of exactly asking that question at the
beginning how can we characterize the
probability that two points x and y in
our data set are clustered together
either both clustered to this subspace Y
or if you flip them both clustered to a
subspace V right
and before we solved that we looked at
an even simpler problem where those two
subspace candidates are one-dimensional
okay and then it becomes quite easy to
see that it'll be a function only of the
inner product between the vectors x and
y this is two dimensions and it's
obvious there but this holds also for D
dimensions okay so if x and y are very
close together than a random subspace
two random subspace this place then the
circle one will be close to both of them
if they're orthogonal then it'll have a
50% chance that you'll be assigned to
the same subspace okay and we can say
that precisely that has the angle
between them increases the probability
of co-clustering decreases and it's a
function of theta okay so in general we
know this is also true not just for
one-dimensional subspaces
but we only know that it is a monotonic
function not a particular monitor mic
function okay so like I mentioned then
given that if we can generalize a model
which says given these type of
measurements we can do clustering then
we have solved our problem and so we we
do that I'm not going to share those
results here but we basically talk about
then all the algorithmic results in
terms of this quantity that's called the
angular separation so we call it Phi of
Q
and basically it'll take over all data
points in all subspaces a data point in
some subspace and look at its inner
products with other points in its own
subspace okay and the cute such inner
product should have absolute value
larger than the inner product with that
point to any other point in any other
subspace okay so you know when I say it
like this it's very clear that if we do
that and we look at inner products or a
monotonic function of them when I
threshold that Q then I'm going to have
a graph that I can cluster right okay so
we basically then prove that like I said
earlier EK ss0 function has this sub
monotonic function of the absolute inner
products as its expectation and then the
work is to prove that there's some
concentration that gives a deviation tau
which is strictly bounded below this
angular separation okay so if the
deviation is below Phi of Q which is why
there's over two then we can guarantee
that the thresholded affinity matrix
will give crack clustering okay and
we've done that in the paper
with different assumptions on subspaces
missing data models noise models and
things like that
okay so here's one of those results just
to give you the flavor we have some
subspaces and our points are drawn from
those subspaces uniformly from the unit
sphere so we have a very nice data
distribution then if Q is basically
large enough and the affinity between
every pair of subspaces is bounded then
we get a correct clustering from the
algorithm with high probability the only
part of this result that's different
from other results in the area is this
term right here that has a probability
that depends on the number of
clusterings we use and the good thing is
that essentially if we can control this
thing
then you know if gamma gets small we can
crank up on B and we can still make sure
this probability goes down okay so these
are other algorithms if anyone's
interested in them I won't talk about
them today since I'm out of time
SSC or sparse subspace clustering is one
of the strongest ones in terms of both
theory and practice so far and we see
that a TSS beats it pretty regularly
here in terms of the angle between
subspaces EK SS can improve over SSC in
terms of error I just want to point out
that EK SS 0 only behaves as well as
thresholded subspace clustering it makes
sense because it just uses inner
products so really doing this
alternating stuff is helping a lot but
we still can't prove anything about that
so okay and then just to show these
results again I want to stress that you
know the algorithm really works nicely
across the board it's not the best in
every column by any means but it's in
the top three and and all the other
algorithms aren't in the top five you
know so we see that when we apply it to
new datasets it it is a really strong
method even though it's quite simple
just a few lines of code okay so in
summary if you're interested the paper
is on archive you know we have this this
pretty simple algorithm with we're very
nice guarantees and like I said
performance that really exceeds those
guarantees and along those lines
the really open work that we're doing
going forward is to try to answer that
question how can we prove that the
performance should be better especially
say in a context where the subspaces the
true data are highly aligned so with
that I thank you for your attention and
happy to take questions
[Applause]
well don't work on more effective ways
to seed k-means so that's guaranteed to
produce some reasonable results there's
also some other work called k-means plus
plus ya know there's a arthur and lots
of this in the subspace something so
people have tried and like some of these
algorithms have baked in like the median
k flats has baked into it they try to do
a better type of initialization that's
sort of analogous to farthest insertion
and and yeah other people have tried and
they see things that work better but
it's all heuristic and people haven't
been able to say things about it and I
guess one of the appeals is some of this
you're workin or ignorant k-means is
that there are some reverse outcomes the
empirical performance
reflects right yeah I don't know either
but you know K subspaces seems
interesting and related and actually
since I've been thinking about it which
is six years ago I I tried to come up
with more ways to make ties between
those two and have only really scratched
the surface when we're just concluding
or so so we're concluding we're
concluding minimum we should thank all
the organizers for the work they did
this is measured concentrated and thanks
to the speakers especially if you're on
the younger side of the room who's gonna
organize the next one all right thanks